ces sommes sont les membres du ku klux
klan arrêté par le fbi comme responsable
du meurtre de madame viola liuzzo
assassinée alors qu'elle revenait de
montgomery après avoir participé à la
marche organisée par le pasteur martin
luther king peu après leur arrestation
et pendant que la police procédait
talent enquête sur les circonstances du
meurtre
quatre de ses hommes ont été remis en
liberté provisoire sous caution
et de toute façon ils ne seront
poursuivis par la justice fédérale que
pour violation des droits civiques
seule la justice de l'alabama pour aller
jugé pour meurtre est bien sûr en
alabama ils bénéficieront de tout
l'appui de cet état où les dirigeants
sont hostiles à la déségrégation malgré
l'énergique prise de position du
président johnson le problème noir n'est
pas simple à régler comme nous
l'expliquent jax albert depuis new york
petit à petit le problème de l'abus
sécurisation dans le sud ne devient plus
un problème entre noirs et blancs
mais un problème entre les blancs du
nord les yankees et les blancs du sud
les confédérés comme aux plus belles
heures de la guerre de sécession
qu'est ce qu'est exactement que le klu
klux cad pour nous autres européens il
ya quelques années encore le klu klux
cannes c'était une association de
quelques excités qui se déguisait la
nuit avec des cagoules et qui brûlait
des croix c'était presque du folklore
malheureusement c'est quelque chose de
beaucoup plus sérieux que ça car les
membres du ku klux cannes prêchent la
haine et il ne presse pas seulement la
haine des noirs finalement on s'aperçoit
qu'ils prêchent la haine de tout ce qui
n'est pas sudistes de tout ce qui n'est
pas conforme à leur conception
personnelle le klu klux kahn représente
environ 30 mille membres ou soixante
mille membres des certains qu'est ce que
c'est que 30000 ou soixante mille
membres dans la masse humaine de 180
millions d'amérique
bien sûr ce n'est qu'une goutte d'eau
mais une goutte d'eau qui donnera tout
de même bien du mal au président johnson
le pasteur martin luther king n'est pas
au bout de ses peines mais il a pour lui
un grand allié et s'est alliée c'est la
télévision je ne sais pas si un jour
l'histoire le dira mais je crois que la
télévision a plus fait pour la cause des
noirs aux états unis que tous les
discours que tous les défilés qui ont
été organisées
car si ces discours et 6 étaient filés
n'avait pas été retransmis par la
télévision
les américains du nord aurait continué à
ne pas se sentir concerné par ce qui se
passait dans le sud
mais lorsque vous êtes chez vous dans
votre salon dans votre chambre devant
votre poste de télévision et que vous
avez devant vos yeux les images des
bagarres en alabama où les images des
démonstrations de masse des noirs dans
le sud
vous ne pouvez pas rester insensible à
ces problèmes vous devenez conscient de
ces problèmes et c'est certainement la
télévision qui a joué un rôle primordial
pour donner aux américains
la véritable proportion de ce problème
noirs tels qu'ils se posent actuellement
dans le sud des états unis ici nous y
sommes avoue paris